parmi les autres astuces proposées par
les experts pour économiser de l'argent
regardez il y avait totalement celle du
sèche-linge regardez c'est un appareil
là qui pose problème on va en termes de
consommation parce qu'il rend bien des
services c'est le sèche-linge on va
faire la petite démonstration alors
c'est parti là il ne tourne pas on
regarde sur l'application
862 watts et maintenant on met le
sèche-linge en route on va attendre un
petit peu
3263 watts au total à l'année le
sèche-linge j'écoute 140 euros en usage
ça veut dire est-ce que vous êtes prêtes
à
diminuer un petit peu la consommation
est-ce que c'est facile pour vous de
diminuer la consommation du sèche-linge
d'avoir un sous-sol donc c'est vrai que
si on descend et qu'on met à côté de la
chaudière par exemple il séchera
beaucoup plus facilement et ça évitera
de l'utiliser plus régulièrement alors
c'est vrai que ça c'est ça c'est une
autre astuce et ça ça peut rapporter
combien alors écoutez en moyenne nous
d'après les estimations qu'on a au sein
de notre fédération c'est à peu près les
chiffres qui ont été cités dans le
reportage à savoir que je dirais se
passer de son sèche-linge c'est une
économie de l'ordre CAC 40 à 200 euros
par an donc c'est pareil il faut
peut-être appeler une chose c'est qu'un
sèche-linge consomme en moyenne deux
fois plus qu'un lave-linge c'est un
appareil qui est très énergivant c'est
le truc exactement c'est pour ça que mes
affaires mouillées
non Cyril parce que je pense que vous
avez comme tout le monde le bon vieille
ton doigt à linge qui est très pratique
exactement la ferme
je le mets comme ça sur le balcon et je
mets à côté le drapeau de l'Algérie et
de la Tunisie j'adore mais c'est vrai
voilà même métier que ma mère
elle avait toujours un drapeau de la
Tunisie on a toujours des rapports de la
Tunisie des petits des grands tu veux
que je t'envoie
chez toi
c'est un truc de fou je vous dis ma mère
avant une nappe c'était une appel mettez
le drapeau de la Tunisie on mange dessus
donc voilà non mais et donc voilà donc
c'est vrai que ça ça coûte très cher il
paraît que sachez-le Valérie Benaim
économise 2000 euros par an en ne
faisant pas de brushing
il y a un autre truc que j'ai lu la truc
que j'ai vu purée je voulais absolument
en parler avec vous et avec les
téléspectateurs cette histoire qu'il
faut pousser le frigo un petit peu du
mur c'est quoi ça pourquoi en fait si
vous voulez c'est ce qui est là aussi
été expliqué dans le reportage c'est une
seule extrait qu'on a pas c'est le seul
truc qui m'a demandé c'est le seul truc
moi ça tombe bien je le connais bien
puisque préparant notamment à cette
intervention il y a effectivement l'idée
vous avez préparé l'intervention
peut-être le seul avantage
et des dessins pour les faire
[Rires]
la petite astuce de décaler
effectivement son réfrigérateur
légèrement du mur ça tient au fait que
un réfrigérateur par définition pour
créer du froid ça a besoin effectivement
d'une production électrique et notamment
de je dirais d'un aspect je dirais un
chauffage qui tient notamment qui retenu
dans les murs et si on décale
effectivement je dirais les gens mais ça
vaut pour tout un tas d'appareils
électroménagers d'une manière générale
si vous décalez un petit peu si vous
laissez respirer finalement malgré votre
appareil électrique en l'occurrence
votre votre réfrigérateur ça lui permet
effectivement d'avoir plus de vitalité
si je peux dire et donc derrière de
faire des économies là aussi alors
regardez on pris une analyse des
dépenses du foyer et de nombreuses
astuces il est temps de voir si les
équipes de capital ont réussi à faire
économiser 20% de budget énergie à cette
famille
c'est donc l'heure du bilan c'était fixé
comme objectif 20% on les a atteint on
les a même dépassés nous avons réussi à
atteindre les 22% simplement avec la
voiture électrique pour Samira et si
jamais vous passez tous les deux à la
voiture électrique là vous vous
retrouvez à 60% de votre budget énergie
est-ce que l'on a bien fait de venir
tout à fait merci
[Applaudissements]
tu vas passer une voiture électrique à
40 000 balles 7000 km par 7000 euros
d'essence il va passer à l'électrique il
roule beaucoup ces gens-là l'électrique
c'est bien mais pas quand tu roules
beaucoup normalement on a passé une
voiture électrique au bout de 10 km
j'étais plus électrique j'étais à
l'essence on s'en [ __ ]
par rapport à son budget essence c'est
marrant les reportages comme ça mais par
rapport à son budget essence c'est
facile de dire passe à l'électrique fais
ci Fais ça c'est dans la vraie vie c'est
peut-être pas alors 5 mesures simples
pour réduire sa consommation
d'électricité mais c'est le chauffage
c'est 60% de la facture énergétique d'un
foyer mais c'est le chauffage bon tout à
fait et on pourrait même aller dans le
sens de cette statistique diminuer son
chauffage d'un seul degré ce qui est je
dirais pas trop gênant sur votre confort
personnel en moyenne c'est 7% d'économie
sur votre facture à l'année c'est à dire
que je vous pour être extrêmement
concret avec vous vous avez une famille
un carton qui a une maison de 100 mètres
carrés à peu près 2000 2500 euros de
factures à l'année avec un seul degré en
moins vous économisez 140 à 160 euros
sur l'année donc c'est quand même c'est
énorme juste pour un petit degré si vous
voulez économiser plus de 1000 euros par
an sinon vous mettez Daniel Moreau dans
le salon
en fait
moi le chauffage vous allez voir la
chaleur viendra tout de suite
imiter la consommation d'eau chaude vaut
mieux prendre des douches froides
ouais c'est pas la peine d'aller de
faire un jacuzzi quand on prend une
douche il a la raison voilà
tu sais quoi moi je prends des douches
froides tous les matins je suis dans une
forte incroyable
circulaire même avec un nidalgo
la lumière c'est ça il faut prendre des
douches un peu froide alors après moi
personnellement je la préfère quand même
un petit peu chaude donc par définition
je vous dirai pas quand même ok
technique ça peut être de régler
effectivement la température du ballon
d'eau chaude au niveau du thermostat et
donc je dirais de baisser de 10 degrés
ce qui fait que voilà
initiative
ça il y a juste le problème c'est quand
je suis pas baisse le robinet
pas celui de Pedro
bla bla baignoire
j'ai demandé à ce que les robinets
soient au centre au milieu ici pas sur
les pas derrière tu sais pour être sûr
qu'on puisse mettre à deux chacun dans
un deux ou trois enfin chacun ouais
[Rires]
il y a également éteindre sa box
internet la nuit débrancher son chargeur
ne permet pas d'économiser de l'énergie
mais il en va différemment pour la box
internet ouais parce que la box internet
à l'inverse des chargeurs est très
gourmandes en énergie donc il y a un
vrai pour le coup il y a un vrai intérêt
pour le trou à effectivement éteindre sa
boxe la nuit mais c'est quand même assez
contraignant notamment ce qu'il faut se
baisser puisqu'on a dit tout à l'heure
[Musique]
je croyais pas rien là-dessus
laver son linge à 30 degrés ah mais ça a
l'air pas bien là
je vais pas le salir de ouf tu laves à
30 regrets ça parait capuche
[Rires]
vous pouvez faire à 30 degrés quand tu
as pas des taches de ouf genre d'enfants
qui ont mangé une glace
encore vendredi dernier
elle est dans ton cul
[Applaudissements]
moi j'ai pas fait une machine moi je
m'appelle machines je voudrais ou pas
quand c'est pas hyper sale ce soir tu
peux très bien laver ta chemise à 30
degrés alors moi j'ai même une autre
astuce plutôt sur la température c'est
de 10 minutes simplement la durée de la
machine au lieu de faire une machine de
2h
bien sûr tout le monde est content
je m'en vais je m'en vais laver les
affaires elle a un sens
[Rires]
voilà et enfin si vous voulez couvrir
les gars les casseroles pendant la
cuisson je le fais ça je le fais
dans ton cul
casserole me tenir tu vas voir non non
mais sans rien moi je le fais ça
effectivement
ça permet de garder la chaleur
exactement